[Musique]
les fêtes sont synonyme de réjouissances
et de rassemblement mais pour certains
ça peut être aussi une source de stress
c
est ce que tout le monde peut recevoir
oui mais faut garder à l'esprit que ça
soit 5 que ça soit des restes qu'on aime
et qu'on sait très bien faire
[Musique]
quand tu manges un courtier à marie
josée et les deux quelle épaisseur ces
matelas préfère elle est épaisse comme
ça tu sais ma belle-mère effets pèsent
comme ça au caire
pourquoi la paix ça une tourtière plutôt
qu'un pâté à la viande ça promet des
chaussées tuiles en attente et toutes
les patates toutes les deux à ckoi vente
à l'arrière du cou à la différence mais
pour moi le porter à rien c'est juste
une tarte aux states
le pâté à la viande a souvent été nommé
routière et c'est un petit peu
l'histoire spécifique du québec qui a
donné au mont tourtière une connotation
plus festive que le pâté à la viande
[Applaudissements]
voici des petites bouchées nouvelles
tendances le cocktail dînatoire que
diriez vous d'un os ou vocaux dans son
gros lot ou d'un pâté chinois dans sa
cuillère même en amuse-bouche la recette
et la main stakes blé d'inde patates
on se demande dès fois pourquoi
certaines traditions du temps des fêtes
perdurent elles ne sont pas toujours si
savoureuse c'est important aussi parce
que selon moi la présentation est plus
importante que le produit final est ce
que vous avez envie de manger l'aspect
quoi on laisse beaucoup de sport si je
pensais faire pour rester comme ça
et josé comment tu l'a choisi ta dingue
on écoute denis cette année j'ai le
privilège de recevoir une bonne que ma
mère a elle fait elle-même se ferme si
elle est depuis toujours le mets
traditionnels par excellence du temps
des fêtes la dinde a subi au fil des ans
plusieurs transformations
ce sont les autochtones qui ont mangé de
la peine en premier parce que c'est un
oiseau d'amérique et quand christophe
colomb à rimont amérique il pense qu'il
est en aide alors ils surnomment cet
oiseau qu'il voit pour la première fois
une poule d'inde elles sont très
populaires à la période des fêtes en
europe on découvre des châtaignes j'vois
pas me les écraser comme vous - faut
penser à quelqu'un qu'on aille à quai et
puis après on va se faire une petite
sauce avec un site de glace et des
canneberges ça va faire noël
pour les manger donc d'enlever la
coaching ça s'est fait très bien une
fois que ces grilles certainement de
belles traditions et demi comme le pen
étonne d'un temps des fêtes tu le gâteau
aux fruits est ce que vous aimez
à noël les québécois dimanche le gâteau
aux fruits les portugais le bolloré les
italiens le panettones moi ça me
rappelle les choux venait de bain de
noël en italie attendait minuit puis
bigorre s'est elle pas les tournées avec
plein de bonnes choses comptent en
commun une vache et poule les deux
donnent du lait du lait de poule c du
lait et des oeufs mais faut faire
attention c'est pas manger noble est
avec un modèle et adore ce seuil en
train des salles immenses et est mon
préféré j'ai joué qui comme le
traditionnel les belges je pense
qu'au bout du globe désigne à la fois
des primes ou bien désigne des raisins
secs ce qui mettait des raisins secs
était pas sûr gentil mais y'en a pas de
prime dans mon gâteau quand je dirais
pas ça christmas pudding sais combien
d'années il l'a fait cette race est leur
cuisine et
172 en fait trois gars ça baigne ça
prend combien tu as mangé après as à
s'épanouir
c'est une tradition quand on répète avec
nos enfants je les imprime ma mère je
les fais avec mes enfants de temps que
vous avez consacré à faire les biscuits
c'est un cadeau vous allez offrir à
quelqu'un et ça n'a pas de prix à
l'image des maisons grande couture qui
font un défilé de mode et bien le
pâtissier lui va préparer sa bûche en
voulant toujours en faire plus pour
surprendre mais le client en tant que
tel ce sont les enfants moi j'ai le
souvenir de l'enfant j'aimais bien ce
petit père noël qu'on trouvait sur la
bûche y avait un petit côté magique sur
ce père noël alors aujourd'hui on les
fait différemment les faits avec des
biscuits en effet sous chamekh
n'enlevons pas la magie de noël
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]